in the Netherlands a court has convicted
three men in absentia for their role in
Downing Malaysia Airlines flight mh17
over Ukraine eight years ago they
include two former Russian intelligence
agents and Ukrainian separatist leader a
fourth defendant has been acquitted the
passenger jet was shot down over eastern
Ukraine killing all 298 people on board
an international investigation
established the plane was hit by a
Russian missile that was fired from
territory in Ukraine that was held by
pro-russian separatists
some of the relatives of the victims
were present at the courthouse is their
reaction
I feel relieved
feel like
it has come to an end and it's been very
fair
and it's been meticulous and it's been
thorough and the evidence has been
weighed and I feel like for those who
want to hear the truth is out there
the sort of stuff that we knew all along
but now a court has gone through a fair
process and has ruled and you've got to
remember while we were in court today we
still have to go home and sit at a
dinner table with our our loved ones and
I think that's
that's never going to go away that
feeling that you know no matter what a
court says or what happens in court
that's still always going to be the case
I personally want to see Russian not
just Hill to account or not just the
four not just the people on trial today
health will count I want to see the
Russian Federation held to account for
m817 but more than that held to account
for the entire war in ucraft which is
now with so many thousands millions of
people are suffering on account of
our correspondent Barbara basil is at
the courthouse in the Netherlands and
she joins us now uh Barbara this trial
started more than two and a half years
ago that's a long wait for justice what
was the reaction there as the verdict
was read out
uh of course the first reactions of some
of the relatives who have now stepped
outside the courtroom in order to talk
to the media are a kind of relief that
Justice in a way is done even though the
four accused were not here in the
courtroom and may probably never go to
jail we don't know this however as we
are sentenced to life arrest warrants
were immediately handed down and so they
can follow the foreseeable future not
leave Russia because they would be
arrested wherever in the world they
turned up before the time being they are
safe there and that of course is an
aspect that some of the relatives here
say still hurts them because they would
of course want to see them go to jail
however justice has been done in a way
maybe in a rather abstract manner but
this Dutch court has really tried to
lead the most the fairest trial possible
under the circumstance answers to sort
of weigh the evidence very carefully to
very carefully think about the chain of
command in 2014 in eastern Ukraine and
the personal responsibility of the
accused and this is the result that we
just heard
now what more can you say about the
verdicts themselves
and the verdict of course was based on a
chain of evidence that was rather
difficult for the Dutch the Dutch Court
to assess because some of it was open
source that was like telephone calls
between the eqs that have been monitored
at the time there were satellite images
how the book missile that was
responsible for the uh or that was of
you know functioning as the missile that
shot down uh the the flight image 17
where it was moved from where it was
moved to and who had the command over
those Rebel militants there who were
active in the area at the time and so
three of the defendants have been now
found guilty that they were in fact the
commanders who did uh who did have
responsibility for what happened in the
area had responsibility for moving this
missile of course with the intent to
shoot down military planes Ukrainian
planes but they by accident they shot
down this passenger plane with its 298
people on board all of them died as we
know and still they are responsible for
what happened at that point
Barbara you've been following this story
closely for for more than eight years
since that fateful crash now uh since
they will likely never go the three uh
that were centers will likely never go
to prison what kind of closure would
will this bring uh to the families
it is for some a part it's some bit of
closure some say they are satisfied with
it because they have seen that a a
criminal court has very carefully
considered the evidence in this case and
said yes they are guilty they're
responsible so justice has been done the
verdict has been spoken so if that
satisfies you in your mind and soul then
this is a step maybe for healing the
wounds that were really inflicted eight
years ago for others however it means
still that they say these people will
never go to jail we don't really expect
it and also the most important Point
nobody no court in the world and nothing
can ever bring their relatives that they
lost in their many tragic cases
um of people who lost their whole
families a wife and three children for
instance some of them on that flight and
whose life more or less has been
destroyed and this court here even
though it tried to be as objective as
Fair and do the best legal job it could
can never bring them back
Barbara basil they're reporting from
Amsterdam thank you very much Barbara